hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
der minecraft und zwar sind wir gerade
in folge nummer 14 you und ich würde
sagen ich fange direkt mit den fans und
zwar wurde der erste fällt mir
zugesendet von meerwasser minecraft er
mein held kraft ich hab einen witzigen
wenn man s 3 und b gleichzeitig drückt
komplize lustige kästchen weil dir und
andere sachen probiert selber aus ist
richtig lustig erst mal dieses f3 + play
sind die hit boxes in der mann den der
sich mox befinden also nicht blöcke
sondern mops und wenn ich jetzt einfach
mal 11 3 und b drücke seht ihr schon
hier zb ob jetzt noch mehr co2 ihr weg
sehen wir beispielsweise schon habe ich
meine coolen gestellt das hier ist genau
die hit box das heißt wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie hierhin schlage treffe ich die
kuh obwohl ich quasi gar nicht die
sommer stehen bleiben egal ich mache mir
bei dem scharf bei dem schaf dem star
schaffte mir keiner ethos hatte ich mal
kurz 53 und bf3 bleibt es beim schaf
nicht aber ihr seht auf jeden fall warte
so bei mir geht es auch bei mir ist die
hid prox da oben gerade sehr verpackt
jedenfalls sind das hier
diese hit box ist in der man quasi tiere
in der man tiere oder oder blöcke
angezeigt werden wenn man hier so ein
blog sieht man ja ok kommen in dem
bereich kaputt machen
beim ob sieht man dann quasi den bereich
in dem man ihn schlagen kann wenn ich
beispielsweise hier geht die crew oder
watte geht die aus der hit box raus
irgendwo hier zum beispiel beim kopf
wenn ich da hin schlage treffe ich sie
nicht weil das nicht der hit box ist
wenn ich allerdings dahin schlagen
direkt auf die kante von der wko direkt
auf die kante von der hip hop schlage
dann treffe ich quasi die kuh das geht
auch mit anderen cops quasi ich kann
auch jetzt einfach keine lobby
vielleicht ein bisschen blöd in kryta
hinsetzen wenn ich das ganze mal auf
einfach machen würde hätte der krieg hat
diese hit box wenn ich da einschlage
schleicht in krieg und wenn ich hierhin
schlage schlage ich hab doch noch auf
die box geschlagen und jetzt bewegt da
bin ich ihn schlage treppchen nicht wenn
ich allerdings noch ein bisschen näher
an die box rand schlage kann ich ihn
schlagen könnt ihr halt relativ gut
sehen ein echter hit box raus geht
treffe ich die kuh nicht obwohl ich
quasi direkt ins verschlag ich muss dann
schon indie hit box rein schlagen danke
an dich mehr wasser und das ist genannt
ist der hit boxen und nicht
lustige kästchen mit zum nächsten
falcons habe ich dann im mai kräftig
gefunden weil ich nie etwas ein bisschen
mal dass minecraft wiki durchgehend mir
da auch ein perfekt zusammen suche damit
ich nicht nur sachen von euch nehmen
weil da ich viele geklaut noch an aus
anderen videos ich habe hier ganz viele
sbornaja da haben wir einmal ein schwein
eine kuh ein schaf eine pilze und ein
dorfbewohner ihr kennt das ok spongetech
darauf dann habe ich ein baby scharf und
der kopf vom baby schaaf ist genauso
groß wie der kopf vom normalen schätzing
ist er hier auch so überdimensional wenn
ich das bei einer kuh mache sehen wie
der kopf von akkus auch so groß wie der
kopf von der mutterkuh recht dass bei
einem scharfmacher sehen wir auch der
kopf vor dem schaf so groß wie das
mutterschafe und bei einer pilz kuba
blabla könnt ihr bei allen mops
aufmachen
nur bei katzen und bei dorfbewohnern ich
habe jetzt keinen bock nennen ozelot
hier zu sparen weil das zehn jahre dort
die mit fisch zu zähmen nur da sind die
köpfe von den kleinen leuten kleiner
also wir sehen hier das ist ein kleiner
billiger wenn der riesigen kopf hätte
wäre es richtig geil
also das liegt nicht an dem text dass es
allgemein so dass nur bei o2 gezähmt zu
leise katzen und bei village an sieht
man euch wenn man diese blöden tipp box
an und bei bildern sieht man bei den
kleinen bei den kindern ankommen die
machen so eine kinderparty sieht man bei
den kindern die köpfe dass die quasi
kleiner sind wirklich und zu dem körper
zusammen passen also quasi develogen
klein und hier ist es einfach ein
kleines schaf aber mit einem normalen
kopf und das auf jeden fall cool hier
sehen wir das nächste schild mojang
aprilscherz mit villiger sound statt
normalen und zwar möchte ich euch da
nicht so ganz was vorlesen was ich
nämlich auch herausgefunden habe
dorfbewohner wurden am ersten april 2014
als scherz genutzt angeblich hatten sie
bei mojang den skin server übernommen
dadurch wurden statt der individuellen
spieler skins ausschließlich
dorfbewohner skins geliefert an diesem
tag seien alle spieler die sonst einen
individuellen skin hatten die
dorfbewohner aus zusätzlich jetzt kommt
mich wurde die
element animation villagers resort pack
2 eingesetzt dass jedes geräusch im
spiel durch eine dorfbewohner stemme
ersetzte die das geräusch beschreibt
wenn es beispielsweise nehmen wie
geregnet hat haben die winzer dann
gesagt so rain rain rain oder wenn die
ins wasser gesprungen sind sagen sie
splash oder wenn man erst abgebaut hat
sagen sie dick dick sondern viele sachen
da blende ich euch jetzt mal ganz kurzen
video ein wo das ganze gezeigt wird es
auf jeden fall richtig witzig und ich
hatte richtig bock man mit diesem
komischen elementen i-männchen pack zu
spielen und es wäre einfach so geil und
ich haben uns ja auch schon gedacht was
wir eigentlich wenn jeder mob quasi
einfach nur kurzen würde andere komische
sachen und die machen das einfach mit
virgin also richtig richtig geil und
richtig witzig effekt wurde mir
zugesendet von massimo und zwar maximal
sich amazon pizza und zwar alle kräftig
hat einen coolen verdeck und zwar wenn
man im gaylord 0 in lava hüpft bekommt
man fall schaden bei wasser nicht falls
diesem feld nimmt würde eher wenig mit
den namen terminator hd das ist
minecraft nickname ok danke terminator
hatte massimo und lava ist ja eigentlich
dick flüssiger als wasser das weiß jedes
kind das sieht man auch schon das fließt
auch viel langsamer und dann müsste man
ja eigentlich auch keinen fall schaden
kriegen wenn ich in wasser geht es da
hab ich so ein ganz kleines wasserbecken
hier ich mache mich mal ganz kurz in den
game mode 0 ich hoffe ich treffe das
becken jetzt bekomme ich keinen fall
schaden weil ich halt in das wasser
gesprungen bin
wenn ich allerdings nach oben fliege ob
es so wenn ich allerdings nach oben
fliegen und in lava das reinmache game 0
kriege ich schon fall schaden und werde
dann erst dann erst kommt jetzt also das
krasse ist natürlich wenn ich in wasser
reingehe passiert mir nix und welchen
lover reingehen verbrenne ich dachte
hier schon sagt wird dann brenne ich
glaube wenn ich allerdings in wasser
rein springe bekomme ich keinen fall
schaden und den lava bekomme ich sogar
schon fall schaden
das heißt wenn ich theoretisch in den
game mode 14 und einfach in diese lager
von ganz weit oben ich glaube hier
müsste sogar schon reichen von ganz weit
oben hier einspringen bin ich tot wegen
fall schaden also
vielleicht außer hohen größe außer
größten großen höhe reingeflogen bin
also die sache ist die was ich damit
sagen möchte ich finde so ein bisschen
komisch und ich finde es sollte zugefügt
werden dass man zumindest und lava
keinen fall schaden bekommt weil aber
bremst ein jahr auch und dann sollte man
schon wenn man rein springt direkt
anfangen zu brennen und trotzdem halt
keinen fall schaden bekommen bei der
wasser bekommt man auf keinen fall
schaden obwohl wasser eigentlich obwohl
man das langsame gebremst wieder als
lover so danke an das team für den fake
dann kann ich anderen für die fed in
zukunft immer mehr wächst aus dem
minecraft vornehmen weil da echt oder
aus minecraft wie die halbwaise echt
auch coole sachen drin stehen und die
pilze oder hinten hat so ein bisschen
ads die hilft auf meiner kiste rum
ich würde sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat zeigt mit einem mag ich und in der
nächsten folge kommen auch wieder
richtig geile sachen an die kommt der
nächste woche sonst würde ich sagen
also was soll ich da noch sagen